passage qu'il a rien à voir son confrère
eric zemmour a sorti un livre il a aussi
été au coeur d'une polémique vous avez
peut-être suivi pour savoir si les
familles issues de l'immigration devait
donner des prénoms français à leurs
enfants
suite aux nombreux remous qui ont
entouré cette polémique le patron de
l'émission on n'est pas couché sur
france 2 laurent ruquier a décidé de ne
pas inviter eric zemmour tout en disant
qu' il n'avait jamais été formellement
programmée alors est ce que c'est la
bonne décision après tout s'il n'est pas
d'accord avec lui il était mort il
n'invite pas même si zemmour a été son
chroniqueur pendant cinq ans en tout cas
c'est pas la vie d'un autre journaliste
et animateur ali baddou qui est
journaliste à france inter qui a invité
lui eric zemmour et qui ne le regrette
pas écoutez moi j'assume complètement ce
choix vous leur ferez pourquoi pas une
émission de débat c'est fait pour
installer un dialogue entre des gens qui
ne sont pas d'accord
sinon ça s'appelle pas un débat et puis
refusé de débattre s'est s'incliné donc
en l'occurrence recevoir eric zemmour il
ya été face à natacha polony raphaël
glucksmann qui lui ont apporté la
contradiction qui n'ont absolument rien
lâché qui ont tenu pied à pied
c'était intéressant et on a même appris
des choses on a appris des choses en
tout cas moi je trouve que c'était une
émission utile rené girard est ce que
laurent ruquier doit inviter ses mots
aussi là pour en vue c'est son droit
mais d'abord je crois que ali baddou a
parfaitement raison
et puis alors je ne sais pas exactement
ah oui un bond à zemmour n'est pas là
titré n'est pas propriétaire de france 2
est donc de cette émission et donc n'a
pas droit à participer à cette émission
si en revanche c'est sur la pression
d'un lynchage médiatique que ruquier
retire cette invention a lassé grave
parce que je suis favorable
personnellement à la liberté
d'expression
eric zemmour dit que les parents issus
de l'immigration devrait donner des
prénoms français à leurs enfants pas
michele platini mais michel platini
c'est son opinion
on peut être d'accord ou pas d'accord
est-ce que absatou est une insulte à la
france personnellement je le pense je
pense pas que ce prénom le nom va là
d'une autre personne d'une hausse de fès
des relations qu'il a dit mais enfin et
ses points de vue pour l'adie voilà je
pense qu'on va t elle aider mais je
pense que ces mots a tout à fait le
droit de dire ça elle a même dit à la
personne vous devriez vous appeliez
corinne on
c'est un style pur voilà mais voulait
donner de l'animation alors on peut tout
à fait ne pas être d'accord avec lui on
peut tout à fait d'ailleurs penser que
ce qui est plus important et une valeur
française effectivement cette
intégration et moi je pense que zemmour
a des intentions pures gillet
assimilationniste et la raison et il est
lui-même sa famille a montré désir
d'assimiler
des simulations mais il a parfois des
excès de langage on peut dire que il a
peut-être pu vexer c'est hapsatou sy 11
ans vous devriez vous appelez corinne et
puis on peut aussi penser qu' il ya une
autre valeur française alors il a tout à
fait raison 1 sur l'assimilation et mot
mais une ou deux valeurs vous pensez
qu'ils nous valeurs qui peut-être plus
importantes sur ces prénoms qui de
valeurs françaises de liberté peut dire
que ben on considère que c'est plus
important les assurés sur la lune
également mais voilà on mais j'ai reçu
ce que zemmour
j'ai moore il faut l'écouter et que ce
serait grave pour la liberté
d'expression en france qu' il n'est pas
le droit de débattre merci renaud girard
anne-sophie bové quel est votre point de
vue sur ce sujet oui mais ça fait du
bien effectivement d'entendre ali baddou
le dire parce que je trouve que ce qui
serait aussi une insulte pour la france
ce serait que ce débat ne puisse pas
avoir lieu parce qu'il ya un vrai débat
effectivement sur cette question de
l'assimilation et j'espère qu'on peut
dire sans s'en prendre plein la figure
que un prénom c'est effectivement qu'est
un des éléments d'une assimilation loin
d'être le seul
en tout cas c'est un des éléments si je
peux juste me permettre de raconter une
anecdote familiale moi j'ai des grands
parents de chaque côté qui sont qui sont
immigrés polonais d'un côté italien de
l'autre mes grands parents polonais ont
choisi de donner un prénom polonais donc
à ma mère qui c'est qui a donc eu un
prénom polonais et un nom de famille
polonais qu
dwdm absolument partout qui a eu
beaucoup de mal avec ce prénom est ce
nom de famille mais elle en a eu aussi
beaucoup de mal parce qu'en fait pour
elle elle était née en france et elle
était française est en fait elle a
toujours souhaité porter un prénom
français et ça fait partie de sa
démarche d'assimilation que de basculer
j'allais dire sur un prénom français et
je ne sais pas si vous le savez mais la
loi a été simplifié quelques temps sur
le sujet c'est à dire qu'on a autorisé à
faire ces demandes-là en mairie et non
plus devant le juge aux affaires
familiales et ma mère qui a 70 ans donc
elle a un âge avancé a fait cette
démarche
voilà donc ça fait partie de sa démarche
de citoyenneté en tout cas de
l'assimilation de notre propre famille
sur le territoire donc j'allais dire que
ce débat puisse être posée est content
puisse la voir entre nous je trouve ça
bon maintenant le style d'eric zemmour
on le connaît c'est une espèce de sabre
ça ça vient c'est assez c'est assez
violent effectivement donc mais il était
face à des chroniqueurs qui sont là pour
lui répondre et je pense qu ali baddou a
raison en tout cas si on souhaite lui
répondre il faut pouvoir le faire
natacha polony l'afer a fait luxe man
l'a fait et juste pour terminer si moi
je pense qu'un prénom si on veut un
garde et un prénom étrangers c'est aussi
tout à fait quelque chose de possible
parce qu'on témoigne d'une filiation à
sa famille voilà c'est une possibilité
comme vous le disait qu'il doit être
laissée mais en tout cas ce débat là
méritent d'être posées sans crispation
et sans lynchage merci de deux pointes
fines aux internautes d'autant plus
intéressant que qu'ils sont contraires
yoran pense que ruquier doit tout à
zemmour et qui ne devrait pas l'écarter
comme cela soudainement allusion sans
doute au au buzz que faisait les émaux
quand il était chroniqueur dans
l'émission tandis que amir sur
lefigaro.fr nous dit mais si on refuse
d'accueillir soral dieudonné et c'est
pourquoi pas zemmour se retrouver sur un
plateau de télévision n'est plus un
droit aujourd'hui qu'à spa grand air
votre point de vue mais évidemment je
suis attaché à la liberté d'expression
et tout le monde a le droit d'exprimer
ses opinions mais j'ai plutôt le
sentiment inverse je pense qu'eric
zemmour est totalement abonnés des
plateaux télé des micros de radio et des
colonnes de journaux depuis un temps on
n'entend que lui tout le temps sur tous
les sujets pour répéter à peu près
toujours la même chose l'histoire du
prénom c'était pas du tout la première
fois qu'ils le qui la faisait tourner en
boucle
moi je trouve ça pèche pas d'accord avec
lui sur le fond c'est là c'est comme ça
tu as progression rien mais bon ça c'est
comme ça mais j'ai pas du tout sentiment
qu'ils soient privés de parole j'ai je
dis ça je dis cela je me suis fait
breaké mart ou non je suis vraiment
désolé je ne se victimise non personnes
en permanence si si si si souvenez il
s'invite à la télé ils s'invitent à la
télé pour dire on cherche à me priver de
ma parole non il n'a jamais dit ça quand
est ce qu'il a dit ça mais il était
encore il ya deux jours je l'a introduit
en radio dire exactement ce que c'est
vrai que les gens demain il ya une
pétition ce qui surviendrait de signer
partage de 1000 personnes donc il
observé mais là il le fait parce qu en
effet là on
fait on lui demande le foll donc si tu
es un nul mérité objectif on demande
alors pu inviter la télé sentant
victimes seraient les motivations ses
bienfaits cynisme à une fille victimise
paille pression ni le couple savait que
je dis c'est qu'il ya des appels des
victimes et des menaces de mort et des
protège-dents dans paris il y avait un
talent sûr mais aussi chez rien des
règlements ils pourrissent une faillite
s'il ne le fait pas une victime je
combats ses idées et il ya un autre truc
qui m'a vraiment profondément choqué
c'est ce qu'il a dit sur roues dans
roues d'assez le cet intellectuel
communiste ce mathématicien qui était
pro algérien membre du priory mérité
douce pau 12 balles dans la peau at il
dit je vais là-bas skoda il faut dire
aussi pourquoi au delà était odeurs que
tu as bon mathématicien était aussi je
crois porteurs de valises c'est à dire
qu'il a du mal à se faire il finançait à
bah voilà alors est-ce qu'ils financent
un débat bien aujourd'hui ça y est ce
qu'ils finançaient ou pas est-ce qu'elle
finance et ou pas il se trouve qu'on
était en guerre contre en algérie
général de gaulle selon moi du tout à
fait raison d'être face à la mairie
il a dit non à des 12 balles dans la
peau parce que ils pensent que odin
aider l'ennemi montlhéry nan sans voix
les rssi beaucoup j'ai dit bastien est
ce que le fait que laurent ruquier soit
animateur d'une émission de télévision
sur le service public lui donne une
situation particulière ou des devoirs
particuliers ou bien n'y a aucun devoir
ami d'eric zemmour et d'ailleurs il
était invité sur france inter si le
service public
il n'y a pas de voie et je comprends que
que enfin qu'un coq n ai pas envie de
l'inviter simplement il avait décommandé
sous pression médiatique qui me semble
un manque d'élégance et de courage il
avait effectivement en premier lieu
décidé d'amener d'invités eric zemmour
suite à la polémique et moi je trouve ça
inquiétant parce que on est passé d'un
discours eric zemmour n'a pas droit de
parler dénoncé eric zemmour au discours
de dénoncer les médias qu'il invite
maintenant le procès c'est en attaque
ardisson on attaque les médias qui font
parler eric zemmour ces news les bolloré
et compagnie alors que c'est comme
l'euro
de faire parler des îles et jamais tout
seul pendant une heure à parler tout ça
l'est toujours des contradicteurs face à
lui on ne donne jamais le micro seul et
je trouve que c'est le rôle du débat
c'est d'inviter des contradicteurs et ce
procès qui est fait aux médias qui
invite eric zemmour je le trouve
extrêmement dangereux et c'est pour ça
et d'ailleurs j'en étais sûr quand j'ai
vu la polémique montée j'étais sûr que
vous qui allez arrêter de l'invité et
enfin le désinvité et c'est bien bien
sûr arriver merci beaucoup à tous les
quatre avaient participé à cette
émission que j'ai trouvé bon à part
passionnante et j'avoue que je suis pas
très objectif
donc c'est à vous d'en juger chers
internautes merci beaucoup et à demain
même heure même endroit pour un nouveau
point de vue bonne soirée
[Musique]